well the golden knights claimed victory
on home ice last night as a colorado
avalanche melted
under the pressure great game chris
matthews joins us live
now with a recap of game four hey chris
hey christian how you doing i'll tell
you what the night's proven they are one
of the best teams in the national hockey
league
if colorado is considered by the sports
books number one team boy vegas is right
there with them
knights rallied from behind last night
to cap a sensational game four win
beating up and stifling that
high-powered colorado avalanche
since the second period of game two
vegas has been the better team both
teams are in denver
tonight preparing for game five tomorrow
and you gotta figure the pressure is now
on the shoulders of the avalanche and
suddenly become a
best of three series abs are 20-0-1
since march
vegas is the only team to come away with
points in denver with an overtime win so
the knights are pretty confident and i
think it goes beyond
the two games i mean you know we got
lots to learn from game one and two in
there too
uh you know obviously on the negative
side game one but game two i
thought we played a hell of a game in
there and deserve better so
um you know i think we're confident in
our game
um we're confident on the road
not an easy task obviously going in
there with their record
and what they've done at home but i
think our guys are excited about the
challenge
certainly are for those who have been at
the fortress and witnessed that crazy
atmosphere coming up at five you'll hear
what the knights are saying about that
electric feeling inside t-mobile nothing
like it
in the nhl the national hockey league
announcing time for game six now
back here in las vegas that's on
thursday remember it's an early start
six o'clock game scheduled 6 p.m not 7.
plan accordingly so you don't miss a
minute of the game and be sure to watch
channel 8 tonight at 6 45 it's monday
that means it is time to face off with
former golden knight derek england